so I was at a bar the other day we're in
a bar
get out oh my god after work okay noted
the first I had my phone out and
somebody said oh is that the new Nokia
blackberry and there's just a sticker I
have that I got at CGI which is a little
like anti-smudge device this is not a
blackberry but it is like a blackberry a
business phone it's Noah Kia's new East
71 we gave it our best of test award
this year in our annual fall test issue
give me some reasons why would why I
would want to use your $500 nokia
instead of my $200 Apple phone well you
wouldn't because you're a blindly brand
lawyer sycophant well what struck us
about this phone is just oh my god
hardware it's thinner than the iPhone
you put these two together it's that
it's thinner it's lighter more light
it's smaller and at the same time it
manages to feel more substantial this is
one of the most impressive pieces of
hardware I've ever seen in see Nokia is
working off of the fifth Rev of s60
which was designed before there was even
really decent broadband connection
speeds so it's made for a less capable
phone on a less capable network I mean
it's more tarted-up than Venessa
wilden's teen this thing has had more
nips and tucks than your worst plastic
surgery case and as a result you get an
operating system that works fine it's
presentable it does all the things you
want to do but could really benefit from
a kick the baby and the bathwater out of
the house kind of situations I mean it's
great okay so on paper it looks really
good but when you get down to actually
using it you're still going through the
same janky menus you're still trying to
struggle with like function keys that
like make the key press a number instead
of a letter and it's like it's not it
just doesn't feel like a phone that's
designed with human beings in mind this
phone is not for this guy this phone I
mean in a lot of circumstances you can
see it in biology you can see it in tech
adversity breeds evolution and
innovation and the wonderful thing about
s60 is that you have a lot of brilliant
people modifying it to suit their needs
and so that the the user base for this
is incredible they have over 3.5 million
registered
users on forum Nokia and all these guys
are modifying these phones to do what
they want them to do I can use this
phone completely not looking I mean I
can unlock it right here I can hold down
my task button and I can zoom down to
Google Maps and I'm right there okay I
can I quite do that with my right I mean
it's the kind of thing that it's for
somebody who wants to be have a higher
than average level of involvement with
their technology on that token it's not
the kind of phone for somebody who just
wants to surf the web to kill time it's
a very productivity oriented phone and
you have a really nice search function
that funk that search is not only the
internet but all of your text messages
and emails then right down here you have
you have for voicemails and you have one
text message all right on the on the
home screen one key access to all these
things this is from Dylan
it says hello Jo it's really original
I'm a Mac created so they don't have
your alt basically your alt tab
essentially here you go to your gallery
here's a picture I took at the
planetarium absolutely no Photoshop
apologies really you can do some pretty
remarkable things with with the photos
on this of course the dynamic range is
not perfect you have to have the right
conditions I'm not gonna sell you iPhone
user on this phone because I don't want
you in my exclusive 3.5 million member
club I want you to stay in your your you
know mass-market iPhone Club
well fine I'm not sure I want to be in
your do things the hard way and brick my
phone whenever I try to you know mod
some kind of abstruse element of its
firmware on my own because I'm on Linux
weenie Club anyways five hundred dollars
unlocked no contract and we gave it a
nine out of ten nine out of ten that's
an awesome phone yeah but it's not for
you
Matt dude this stupid iPhone is not
working like a me to find out how to
like make a phone call on it what's
what's what's going on with this thing
Danny this isn't a phone this is an iPod
Touch dude look you should be able to
tell because it is dramatically thinner
than the actual iPhone Oh mad you know
what I don't like what do you not like
the fact that there are certain products
that Apple released recently perhaps the
the iPod Nano that have a cool features
like shake to shuffle and this does not
have it it does not have shake to
shuffle but it has an accelerometer it
does something that my dad Oh can't okay
show me I mean you can the iPod Nano I
can't say I like that you know you can
play games with this one that you can't
even think about doing with the iPod
Nano it's for example this is a sport
origins game I can use it to control
model creature here that's you yeah so
you know exactly but if you want to
watch a real TV show like this this this
fringe show here which which I almost
wish which I hadn't spent my dollar 99
on but still there are good TV shows you
can watch and they're gonna look great
on this if you're on the plane or
something it's got plenty of battery
life you don't always have to reinvent
the wheel the previous iPod Touch was a
great and sorry for the cliche it was a
great you know it's a great device it
let you do most of the things this did
without the applications you can do that
with those now you have to pay right
this has got a 32 gigabyte hard drive
okay so that's actually kind of a lot of
memory yeah so unless you like some sort
of like BitTorrent freak you're probably
not gonna max it out right if you go
running with it this now talks to your
iPod plus Nike equipped tennis shoes
I'll track your run or me get back you
can see you know how far you've gone and
that's that's it that's your friend yeah
so that's different from the last iPod
badges it did not do that
okay now this this one uh best of test
2009 2008 ball test right in fact it did
yes it got an 8 out of 10 which say that
means it's an excellent product you know
food quality and buy it immediately
don't make calls and you don't have to
pay for a service plan true to save
money